Horror icons, primetime stars, criminals,
and queens: the cast of The Craft has done
it all.
Want to know which breakout performer captured
Ben Stiller’s heart?
Wondering why you recognized the pilot from
Sharknado?
Keep watching to learn all about this ensemble
cast!
Sarah Bailey, played by Robin Tunney, is a
bit unsure of herself, and not just because
she recently transferred to a new school.
She doesn't know how or why she's able to
do the things she can, and fears she’ll
lose control of her powers and hurt the people
around her.
Following The Craft, Tunney got another dose
of the supernatural in 1999’s iconically
bad End of Days.
She plays the role of Christine York, a woman
whom the Devil, played by Gabriel Byrne, has
selected to be the mother of the antichrist
— unless Arnold Schwarzenegger has anything
to say about it!
"Christine, come to me.
I am the one you’ve been waiting for.
I am the answer to your prayers."
For 2000's critically panned Vertical Limit,
Tunney took on the role of Annie Garret, a
trapped mountain climber in need of rescue
by her brother, played by Chris O’Donnell.
Tunney later appeared in 2006's period crime
drama Hollywoodland, which told a fictionalized
version of the death of Superman actor George
Reeves, portrayed by Ben Affleck.
She plays Leonore Lemmon, Reeves' fiancee
at the time of his death.
In 2008, Tunney took up the role of Teresa
Lisbon, boss and love interest to the title
character on USA's procedural drama The Mentalist.
More recently, she had a lead role as Maya
Travis on ABC's ill-fated legal drama The
Fix.
Fairuza Balk plays the ambitious and spiteful
role of Nancy Downs.
Unsatisfied by the insurance payout from her
late stepfather’s death, and jealous of
Sarah’s natural talent, Nancy goes to drastic
measures to strengthen her powers and outclass
her friends.
The same yearThe Craft hit theaters, Balk
washed off the goth makeup and popped in some
custom incisors for the role of human-cat
hybrid, Aissa in the remake of The Island
of Dr. Moreau.
Two years later, Balk brought to life another
complicated, power-hungry young woman for
1998's American History X.
She played Stacey, the soon-to-be ex-girlfriend
of recently former Neo-Nazi skinhead, Derek
Vinyard, played by Edward Norton.
The very same year, she took on the decidedly
lighter role of Vicki Vallencourt, love interest
to Adam’s Sandler’s character, Bobby Boucher,
in the sports comedy The Waterboy.
In 2015, Balk landed a recurring role on the
Showtime drama Ray Donovan, playing Ginger,
a prostitute who befriends the title character's
father.
In Amazon's series Paradise City, Balk plays
the role of Lizzie Thomas, the grandmother
to Faith, the daughter to series lead Johnny
Faust, played by Andy Biersack.
Bonnie Harper, as played by actor Neve Campbell,
starts out on the quiet side.
Covered in mysterious burn scars, she does
her best to hide as much of her body as possible.
When Sarah shows up and the witches have their
fourth, she manages to remove her scars completely,
and gains newfound confidence in her appearance
from then on.
The Craft really put Campbell on the path
to being a '90s it-girl.
The same year The Craft came out, she starred
as protagonist Sydney Prescott in Wes Craven’s
teen horror flick, Scream. Campbell went on
to reprise the role for the 1997 sequel Scream
2, as well as 2000’s Scream 3 and 2011's
Scream 4.
Following Craven’s death in 2015, Cambpell
also appeared in Scream 5, which came out
in January 2022.
In addition to the teen horror film genre,
Campbell has also found success on the small
screen.
In the popular drama, Party of Five, she stars
as orphan Julia Salinger.
She also enjoyed a recurring role as political
strategist LeeAnn Harvey on Netflix's political
thriller drama House Of Cards.
Rochelle Zimmerman, played by Rachel True,
rounds out the quartet of young witches.
In addition to dabbling in witchcraft, she
is also a member of the school's diving team.
Despite her diving talent, she’s bullied
relentlessly by her teammate, Laura.
Laura's racist taunts lead Rochelle to seek
revenge, eventually causing the superficial
pretty girl to lose her hair and become despondent.
Two years after filming The Craft, True joined
the cast of Half Baked.
In the dim stoner comedy, she played the super
cleverly named Mary Jane Potman, opposite
Dave Chapelle’s character, Thurgood Jenkins.
Mary Jane is Thurgood’s love interest in
the film, eventually forcing him to choose
between sex or smoking weed.
"Marijuana is terrible.
It’s a gateway drug.
Everybody knows it leads to other stuff."
Beginning in 2002, True took on the role of
Mona Thorne in the UPN sitcom Half & Half,
which followed the unexpected friendship between
Mona and her half-sister, Dee Dee, played
by Essence Atkins.
True appeared on the show throughout its entire
four-season run before it was canceled in
2006.
More recently, True appeared as Jonni Valentine
in Sharknado 2: The Second One.
True plays the first officer aboard Flight
209, a plane attacked by airborne sharks.
Unfortunately, she doesn’t last long.
The same year, she appeared in Blood Lake:
Attack of the Killer Lampreys as Marcy, a
member of the fish and wildlife service who
falls prey to the title monsters.
Actor Skeet Ulrich took on the role of the
repugnant Chris Hooker.
Like many archetypal campus kings, Chris maintains
a good guy persona when the occasion calls
for it, feigning innocence and side-stepping
the truth like an All-American running back.
When Chris doesn’t get what he wants, the
charm turns off and the mean-spirited bully
comes out.
Sarah manages to tame him with a love spell,
but this eventually backfires when Chris becomes
obsessed and dangerous.
Ulrich had a prolific run in the mid '90s,
with The Craft serving as one of his five
film appearances in 1996 alone.
Later that year, he joined co-star Neve Campbell
in the franchise-launching Scream, though
his character didn't enjoy the same longevity
as hers.
Ulrich played Billy Loomis, Sydney Prescott's
boyfriend and initial murder suspect.
After revealing himself as one of the two
killers, alongside his friend and co-conspirator
Stu, played by Matthew Lillard, Sydney shoots
him in the head.
The actor went on to appear as Vincent, the
model-turned-assailant, in 1997's acclaimed
As Good as it Gets.
Two decades later, Ulrich took up the role
of Forsythe Pendleton Jones II on the CW’s
Riverdale.
Ulrich played the reformed criminal, father
to Jughead, and eventual Riverdale sheriff
for five seasons before departing the series.
In an interview with Variety, Ulrich stated,
“I’m leaving Riverdale because I got bored
creatively.”
Mitt, Chris’s slacker best friend, is brought
to life by actor Breckin Meyer.
Mitt is goofy, but a loyal friend to Chris.
He's seemingly got nothing but wisecracks
to offer, until he gets an eyeful of a scar-free
Bonnie, that is.
In 1998, Meyer appeared in 54 alongside fellow
'90s up-and-comer Ryan Phillippe, with the
two playing bartenders at the infamous New
York City hotspot.
In 2000's sophomoric sex comedy Road Trip,
he landed the lead role of Josh Parker, a
man forced to travel across the country in
order to stop a sex tape he made with another
girl from being delivered to his long-distance
girlfriend.
The following year, Meyer played lawyer Nick
Schaffer in the 2001 comedy Rat Race, where
he competes in a race across the desert funded
by John Cleese’s character, Donald Sinclair.
On the small screen, Meyer played Jared Franklin,
one half of the title duo on Franklin & Bash.
Jared, an unorthodox lawyer, works alongside
his partner and long-time friend Peter Bash,
played by Mark-Paul Gosselaar.
Meyer also joined The Craft co-star Robin
Tunney in the 2019 legal drama The Fix, playing
the L.A. district attorney, Charlie Wiest.
Laura Lizzie, played by Christine Taylor,
is kind of the worst.
She's openly and unapologetically racist to
Rochelle, taunting the young woman and deriding
her hair.
From yelling "Shark!"
in the middle of Rochelle's dive to just all-around
nastiness, Laura's eventual comeuppance is
satisfying, if not a bit guilt-inducing.
Outside of her role in The Craft, we assume
Christine Taylor is perfectly nice.
Why else would Ben Stiller have married her
in 2000?
Taylor and Stiller would go on to appear in
2001's Zoolander and 2004's Dodgeball: A True
Underdog Story.
In Zoolander, viewers will recognize Taylor
as the fictional TIME Magazine journalist
Matilda Jeffries, whose hit-piece makes title
character Derek Zoolander look like a fool.
In Dodgeball, she portrays bank lawyer Kate
Veatch, where she dodges both balls and unwanted
advances from Stiller’s character, White
Goodman.
Taylor has a cameo in the 2008 action flick
satire, Tropic Thunder, appearing in the film-within-the-film,
Simple Jack.
Beginning in 2016, she took on the recurring
role of Gail in HBO’s series, Search Party.
She plays the rich boss to Alia Shawkat’s
character, Dory.
Spanish actress Assumpta Serna took on the
role of Lirio for The Craft.
Viewers first meet Lirio when Nancy and the
gang take Sarah to her bookstore and proceed
to shoplift from it; Sarah surprises the spiritually
inclined shopkeeper by actually paying for
something.
The bulk of Serna's filmography has come in
international fare, though she has logged
plenty of English-language projects in the
years since The Craft premiered.
Among those is the 2003 TV movie, Henry VIII.
She later appeared in the 2008 indie crime
drama Uncertainty, starring Joseph Gordon-Levitt
as the protagonist, Bobby.
Serna appears as Sylvia Montero, mother to
Bobby’s pregnant girlfriend, Kate, played
by Lynn Collins.
Actor Cliff De Young plays Sarah's father
in The Craft.
While Sarah has a complicated relationship
with her father, she’s relieved to discover
he’s still alive despite what Bonnie, Nancy,
and Rochelle lead her to believe.
In the movie’s final scene, Sarah’s father
can be seen packing up the car while Sarah
confronts Nancy and Bonnie.
The year after The Craft was released, De
Young appeared in 1997's crime thriller Suicide
Kings.
De Young plays Marty, the lawyer to former
Mafia boss Charlie Barret, portrayed by Christopher
Walken.
When Charlie is kidnapped by a group of well-meaning
students in need of ransom money, Marty looks
into his employer’s disappearance.
De Young has racked up an impressive who's-who
list of primetime TV drama appearances as
well.
He plays a lawyer on The Practice, a reporter
on the NCIS precursor JAG, a doctor on Melrose
Place, and John Ramsey in the TV movie, Getting
Away with Murder: The JonBenet Ramsey Mystery.
Other highlights include a four-episode stint
as Agent John Bonacheck on The Young and the
Restless and a two-episode arc on Grey's Anatomy.
De Young's most recent credit came as Joe
Logo in the mockumentary Reality Queen!
The show follows London Logo, Joe’s daughter,
portrayed by Julia Faye West, who's determined
to prove she's more than just a vapid celebrity
debutante and heiress.
Nancy's mother, Grace Downs, is brought to
life by actor Helen Shaver.
She may have lousy taste in men, but she seems
to luck out when it comes to their deaths.
Despite the uncanny circumstances surrounding
her late husband's passing, Grace is too busy
living the good life to worry about things
like mysterious life insurance policies
Shortly after The Craft hit theaters, Shaver
appeared in the direct-to-video sequel Tremors
2: Aftershocks.
She took on the role of Dr. Kate Reilly, a
geologist whose field work brings her in close
proximity to the Graboids, a species of subterranean
creature that's terrorizing a Mexican oil
field.
After original Tremors character Fred Ward,
portrayed by Earl Bassett, saves Dr. Reilly’s
life, she becomes his love interest.
That same year, Shaver landed a main cast
role in Poltergeist: The Legacy, playing Dr.
Rachel Corrigan for four seasons of the horror
series.
Rachel, a skilled psychiatrist, is invited
to join the titular secret occult society
after receiving their aid, though her cynicism
keeps her from believing in the paranormal.
Shaver also appeared in the 2007 indie drama
Numb.
She plays Audrey, the mother to depressed
screenwriter Hudson Milbank, portrayed by
Matthew Perry, whose spiral of detachment
leads him to seek psychiatric help.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.